j'ai un côté très inconscient très
enfantin moi c'est je me dis bah je
reviens en me disant évidemment toutes
les portes sont ouvertes pas du tout
vous êtes une vraie bête de scène c'est
c'est amusant d'ailleurs puisque comme
vous le disiez vous avez fait toute
votre carrière vous en vendant des
disques combien de disques 70 millions
et et votre la seule scène c'était en 63
c'était vraiment à mes débuts ou j'étais
une gamine débutante et bah c'est comme
ça bon ma vie s'est organisée comme ça à
mon à mon grand regret mais l'avantage
que j'ai c'est que
aujourd'hui moi j'ai 53 ans et je suis
complètement éclaté parce que je suis
pas d'abord je suis pas usée parce qu'on
m'a vu dans très peu d'endroits et moi
quand je vois aujourd'hui à l'âge que
j'ai les salles l'âge des gens je vois
des gamins qui qui chantent les rois
mages qui chantent des chansons que j'ai
enregistré il y a 20 ans 25 ans et les
chansons
d'aujourd'hui je trouve ça excitant
possible quoi qui n'a pas voulu est-ce
que c'est votre producteur qui vous a
empêché de faire de la scène oui enfin
c'est une bon il faut il faut remonter
très très loin mais disons que c'est
vrai voilà l'époque est disons qu'en 63
j'ai fait une une première tournée j'ai
traversé la France et puis bon j'ai eu
des problèmes de santé bon je me suis
arrêtée parce que j'avais perdu 15 kg il
fallait que je m'arrête donc je me suis
arrêté et puis bon voilà après ça s'est
organisé différemment et puis je suis
rentrée dans un système de disque où
j'ai sorti un disque tous les de mois et
j'avais un disque qui était encore
classé dans les 5 premiers du PARAD j'en
avais déjà un autre qui était en promo
qui commençait ce qui fait que je suis
devenue une une espèce de de machine à
enregistrer le seul regret que j'ai
c'est que quand je vois le plaisir que
c'est d'être sur une scène de de de
partager cet amour avec les gens je me
dis qu'on a c'est un peu dommage qu'on m
privé de tout ça l'image que l'on a de
vous que l'on a eu de vous est-ce elle
vous correspond ou pas est-ce que vous
avez eu le sentiment d'être trahi ou pas
pour non c'est pour ça que j'ai été
pendant les années la chanteuse en
playbac celle que c'était pas moi qui
chantait c'était quelqu'un d'autre c'est
aussi parce que je faisais pas de scène
tout cette espèce de de d'images choses
qu'on entretient qu'on véhicule et tout
c'est parce que j'avais jamais fait
l'Olympia parce que j'avais jamais fait
tourner parce que c'est facile parce que
vous êtes peut-être l'une de celles
parmi d'ailleurs d'autres artistes mais
sur lesqueles il y a eu le plus de
fantasme de délire est-ce qu'à un moment
donné vous êtes dit c'est trop la
notoriété ah ça m'a atteint attends à 18
ans j'allais ple dans les bras de ma
mère mais c'est vrai que c'était
toujours la même chose qui revenait bon
c'est comme ça au bout du compte
qu'est-ce qu'il en reste de tout ça pas
grand-chose et vous vous étiez prêt à
vivre cette gloire quand c'est arrivé ou
pas moi sincèrement pas du tout moi
j'étais non moi je suis petit tombé du
nid moi je suis arrivée là-dedans je je
voulais faire ça parce que bon c'était
ma vie moi je voulais être dans le
cirque j'ai fait du trapèze je voulais
être petit ras de l'Opéra je me serais
jamais vu dans un bureau comptable
c'était pas mon truc du tout d'illeurs
si j'avais su faire les comptes ça
serait sent ça c'est ça on va en
reparler du ent c'est une autre histoire
mais je trouve ça drôle bon
mais non moi je c'était c'était ma vie
mais je crois que c'est dans mes veines
depuis que je suis toute petite alors
quand vous disiez que vous n'étiez pas
préparé à ce succès comment ça s'est
manifesté alors problème de
contrat pendant des années vous n'avez
pas eu 20 ans c'est ça vous n'avez pas
eu le contrat que que vous non j'ai j'ai
j'ai j'ai non mais moi j'étais mineur
c'est mes parents j'avais 16 ans c'est
mes parents qui ont signé un contrat bon
mais je pense que ça
correspond à toute une époque quoi
c'était l'époque des premiers
producteurs des
premiers premiers personnages
indépendants qui s'occupaient d'artistes
donc on a été un peu les pionniers si
vous voulez alors c'est vrai que
beaucoup d'entre nous que ce soit Johnny
Claude François enfin je veux dire on
est tous passés par là au départ on a
travaillé
pour pour la gloire on dira c'est vrai
que j'ai je suis quelqu'un qui qui a eu
un contrat où moi j'ai été salarié
pendant des années on peut pas on peut
pas me reprocher d'avoir fait ça pour
l'argent quoi donc c'est tout mais mais
c'est vrai que je suis quelqu'un qui qui
sert un peu d'exemple parce que on na
jamais vu un artiste salarié mais bon
alors il y a des moments j'en veux il y
a des moments j'en veux plus il y a des
moments je pardonne mais il y avait un
côté
artisanal qui était sympathique qui qui
a un peu dit aujourd'hui c'est une
énorme machine à clinex quand même alors
pourquoi après vous êtes arrêté pendant
pendant une dizaine d'années vous êtes
revenu et surtout à la scène bah parce
que si je suis revenue c'est pour faire
de la scène uniquement mais pourquoi
vous étiez malheureuse à un moment donné
vous êtes par je suis dit voilà d'abord
j'avais besoin de faire le point donc
j'ai arrêté c'était volontaire c'était
c'est siamant c'est et et je regrette
pas sincèrement je regrette pas l'avoir
fait parce que d'abord j'été capable
d'affronter euh le fait que mon
téléphone ne sonne plus parce que
c'estis quand on est dans un
tourbillon ce métier c'est un tourbillon
la gloire c'est un tourbillon on voit
rien tout le monde vous aime vous êtes
le plus grand le plus beau le plus
talentueux vous fait des petites
calipettes des petites courbettes tris
saérieux enfin bon tout ça je veux dire
on le voit pas quand on est dedans on
est persuadé moi on est persuadé qu'on
est bar brassraisonne vous comprenez
bien faut quand même être logique parce
que on est tellement entouré de gens qui
vous sensent et qui vous
qui siiv dans les pipos qu'on ne voit
rien donc tout ça tant qu'on n pas
capable de de de le regarder en face de
l'affronter de savoir que chez là euh
bah c'est peut-être pas non plus ce que
j'ai imaginé que j'étais c'est peut-être
aussi une image un peu lourde à porter
ça a peut-être aussi un côté un peu
quand je dis des fois on me dit mais
pourquoi c'est vrai je dis moi j'ai
j'avais TR ton par couette dit mais en
fait comment vous pouvez dire une chose
pareille mais je dis ça c'est pas
péjoratif moi mes couettes c'est c'est
c'est ce qui m'a c'est ce qui a fait mon
image B j p C mes couettes mais à des
moments sincèrement à 53 ans les
couettes je trouve qu'elle pèse 3 tonnes
c'est pas méchant ce que je dis c'est
simplement il il faut il fallait il
fallait s'arrêter justement pour qu'il
n'y ait plus de
couette je crois non c parce que ça
c'est votre parcours vous pensez que ça
arrive à tout le monde ce qui vous est
arrivé c'est image de départ et
qu'onarrive pas à la faire évolu
absolument moi je pense qu'on se sort on
est on vit malheureusement dans un pays
où tout est dans les petit dans les
petits casiier alors moi j'ai le casier
chanteuse populaire c'est là avec ses
couettes etante populaire avec des
couettes voilà
alors c'est pas méchant et je les Renis
pas mes couettes je les adore elle est
genti elle est charmante un peu conc
mais charmante quand même bon et ça pas
moyen de le balayer ça m'a pris du temps
au jour d'aujourd'hui je ne suis pas
sûre ENF si là j'exagère mais je pense
que le fait de m'être arrêté j'ai changé
d'ailleurs mon discours mon discours
n'est plus le même c'est obligatoire
vous avez aussi vieilli il y a des très
peu ma
chère non faut rire tous écoutez faut
rire moi je pense qu'on fait le plus
beau métier du monde mais il faut
prendre tout ça avec du recul la gloire
c'est complètement éphémère c'est rien
ce que je voudrais dire moi si j'avais
un conseil à donner à à tous les les les
les jeunes qui arrivent qui ont be de
talent et qui je vont faire des grandes
carrières quoi n'oubliez jamais que tout
ça c'est du
vent c'est très égoïste que je veux dire
mais il faut penser à soi moi j'aime me
remettre en question j'aime alors je
m'arrête 10 an après vous me dites mais
enfin pourquoi elle revienent alors vous
n'avez pas répondu d'ailleurs pourquoi
voilà vouloir revenir sur la scène et
chanter de nouveau parce que vous auriez
pu trouver d'autres plaisirs si je veux
faire vraiment aller jusqu'au bout de
mon rêve je peux pas le faire sans avoir
fait de la scène donc en fait c'est
c'est sur une frustration quelque chose
qui que vous n'avez manque pas aller j
c'est un manque c'est un manque des gens
c'est un manque de de de de
transpiration de sur de trac de moi j'ai
pas envie d'avoir des regrets moi je
veux dire demain j'ai envie de faire moi
je suis quelqu'un qui rêve la vie c'est
les rêves j'ai un côté très inconscient
très enfantin moi c'est je me dis bah je
reviens en me disant évidemment toutes
les portes sont ouvertes pas du tout
toutes les portes sont fermés on rame
comme un malade c'est là qu'on se rend
compte que on peut s'appeler chez là
avoir vendu so 70 millions de dis avoir
défrayé les chroniques et fait beaucoup
de télévision le métier change les gens
chang les gens qui sont en place et ben
je là s'en fout et voilà et c'est la vie
qui est comme ça ça a été si difficile
de revenir à partir du moment où vous
avez non c'est difficile de sortir un
disque aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui vous
agace aujourd'hui qui vous énerve c'est
de ne pas avoir de de maison de disque
et avoir un public qui est là fidèle qui
vous attend des vrais fans et vous ne
comprenez pas ça ne fonctionne pas
ensemble euh sincèrement je sais pas si
ça m'énerve ça ça me surprend mais si
vous voulez on me demande de faire de la
télévision on me demande de faire des
chot télés on me demande en spectacle ça
marche très très bien je comprends pas
pourquoi maintenant c'est le
disque carère à l'envers y a toujours il
y a toujours quelque chose qui va pas
mais si c'était simple ça serait pas un
métier excitant non plus quoi mais mais
c'est vrai que par contre je ne
m'attendais pas personne d'ailleurs à un
échange
parce qu'après ça c'est de l'amour ça
c'est la seule chose que personne ne
peut nous retirer c'est une chose qu'on
on a nul part ailleurs et je crois que
c'est ce qui fait qu'on s'accroche et
qu'on a envie de continuer pour ne rien
manquer sur ma chaîne Ina mire Duma
abonnez-vous et activez la
[Musique]
cloche